ces deux partis étaient au second tour
de l'élection présidentielle ce sont les
deux grands perdants de la soirée
le rassemblement national et la
république en marche se classe 3e et 4e
des régionales en île de france
le rn obtient 10 79% des voix 32 mille
bulletins en moins par rapport au
premier tour et perd du terrain par
rapport à 2015 à l'instar des autres
régions le parti disposait de 22 sièges
sous la précédente mandature à la région
ce sera 16 sur les six prochaines années
première explication de la tête de liste
jordan bardella l'abstention record qui
s'élèvent en ile-de-france à plus de 66%
en ile de france comme ailleurs la
réélection par défaut dans un désert
démocratique de la présidente de région
valérie pécresse doit appeler chacun à
la modestie devons nous résoudre à
admettre que la france aura été
indifférente à ce double scrutin
illisible désorganisée et certainement
trop loin d'un peuple épris de liberté
retrouvée
lassé d'un an et demi de vie sous
tutelle j'accueille les résultats de ce
soir avec humilité
recul également confirmé dans les
yvelines avec un score inférieur de
trois points par rapport au scrutin de
2015 le rassemblement national passe de
trois à deux sièges yvelinois au conseil
régional conseiller sortant l'ex maire
de mantes la ville cyril note ne se
maintient donc pas dans l'assemblée il
faut pour lui se mettre d'ores et déjà
au travail en vue de la présidentielle
les sortants ont été assez facilement et
brillamment réélu c'est une réalité on
en prendra acte va falloir évidemment
créer une dynamique puisque l'absence de
victoire nous prive de cette dynamique
pour lancer la présidentielle c'est à
marine le pen de bien travailler sur ça
sur sa campagne sur la manière dont elle
va aller à la rencontre des français
dans quelques mois du côté de la
république en marche les succès de
l'année 2017 avec la présidentielle et
les législatives semblent bien loin
la liste conduite par laurent saint
martin se positionne dernière de ce
second tour des élections régionales en
ile-de-france 9,62 % des suffrages
trente mille bulletins de moins qu'au
premier tour
après le scrutin des municipales la
majorité présidentielle confirme ses
difficultés à s'implanter localement une
dynamique qui prend du temps les
présidents et présidentes sortante quand
je sortait aujourd'hui ont souvent passé
beaucoup de temps dans l'opposition
c'est vraiment important de bien l'avoir
à l'esprit c'est à dire qu'une
implantation locale ça prend du temps et
je sais que vous êtes habitué avec la
majorité présidentielle à ce qu'on sorte
toutes les deux d'un coup eh bien
peut-être que ces scrutins sont là aussi
pour rappeler que une implantation
locale ça prend du temps et que c'est du
travail auprès des concitoyens et nous
franchissons aujourd'hui une belle étape
qui est celle de la création du groupe
de la majorité présidentielle la région
ile-de-france la république en marche
aura tout de même son groupe au conseil
régional avec 15 candidat élu dans les
yvelines le parti obtient deux sièges
pourvus par les députés jean noël barrot
et aurore bergé
pour cette dernière qui fait partie
désormais des 209 conseillers régionaux
c'est maintenant que débute l'ancrage
territorial du mouvement macro nist on
n'existait pas au moment des dernières
élections régionales et départementales
aujourd'hui on existe il y en a vocation
à durer et moi c'est aussi pour ça que
je voulais être élu et conseillère
régionale certains il aimerait que la
république en marche ce soit qu'un
épiphénomène une petite parenthèse de la
vie politique et qu'elles se referment
aussi vite qu'elle est arrivée
ça c'est ce que voudraient les partis
traditionnels mais les partis
traditionnels ils ont échoué pendant
très nombreuses années citons la
république en marche n'aurait pas pu
faire élire emmanuel macron à la
présidence de la république et je serai
pas députés aujourd'hui si droite et
gauche avaient réussi en échec
localement la république en marche le
rassemblement national reste cependant
en tête des intentions de vote des
français à un an de l'élection
présidentielle
emmanuel macron et marine le pen
seraient bien au second tour du scrutin
selon un dernier sondage ipsos sopra
révélé ce 28 juin